so I throw six let's see if I can do it
Wow oh my god I'm really good okay see
my head does work oh my god oh oh oh dad
I'm doing okay I can't believe it why
does revive turn seconds all right try
this again Hey Oh
[Music]
oh right in the grundle impossible 70
wait ha yeah yeah that did it oh ho go
pro
oh god this doesn't seem like it's gonna
be fun you'll never catch me let's try
this with confidence let's try it again
with less confidence my forehead
[Music]
missed me douche nozzle now you'll see
why did that happen don't mind
something doesn't feel right about this
no you have the baby fix the hook not
the babies just just get in baby just
get in
oh god just get in the friggin thing Wow
oh yeah the whole baby RPG shooting oh
oh oh really why are you telling him
that you mean this book well oh I'm
still playing oh [ __ ] I thought it was
like well that's the end of that what in
the world oh I'm horrible where did I
get this sorry about your ferraro oh no
I'm a menace to society from the Walmart
these four people well only one left how
will this Wow hello is that a Shogun Oh
how do you know why did I did it WWE 2k
six
I'm gonna lay the smackdown ow oh wait
come back please hi
why are you humping my body my dead dead
body
oh good I'm so bad at these ha gotcha
I'm the loving tender embrace no one
survived you know this isn't exactly how
WWE goes not that I've watched W do that
you horrible man I don't wanna I don't
want to give up anywhere I don't want to
do anything I don't wanna get to the
winner's circle
I'm fine right
oh it does feel like a ninja but I bet
death is this easy all it's not easy
okay I'm just gonna quit now while I
have my luck can you survive probably no
oh that's a thing I thought that was a
decoration huh how is oh no I had to
sacrifice my liver I had to sacrifice my
pelvis sorry son looks like you're gonna
be fine yep let's just try to yeah yeah
yeah that's the stuff okay so how do I
hop that does one how does one do how
does one do this level I'm gonna die for
it
well that I I'll just crawl cuz that's
logical oh hi son
how's it going don't mind me
breakdancing a little bit I am flip the
wrong way around now ha come on we
always got son don't get in my way you
little bastard damn it sorry my dead leg
is getting in my way I'm right here huh
I got it
any second now Oh Roy Oh God
oh now I'm getting farther away this is
stupid sure wanna beauty pie quiz how
much do I know about PewDiePie I bet not
a lot hold ctrl on the way down well
just beautify his real name huh I wonder
about this one well oh [ __ ]
Wow there we go [ __ ] or advance boy
that's terrifying I'm not over there
hope you're okay with me just
oh hi how's it going there buddy how you
doing you doing good
oh hey hey now don't mind my bleeding
shoulder hello it's Gary face wow this
is thoroughly spookified
I wonder what come on oh why oh god but
oh god no you son Oh Oh
my grundle Oh must bundle oh no no no no
missed me okay now I go whoa whoa are
you doing buddy I'm gonna just you know
do this
sure kicked your ass somehow hi oh oh oh
oh oh I'm sorry I guess huh okay I'm
racing oh god damn it I have no idea
what's I didn't do the TNT okay oh god
I'm so bad at this I should have opened
the oh god alrighty then I'm Way behind
but at least my goats bleating so that's
nice I guess everything we got a problem
here
that is a loud beer so how am I supposed
to hit this okay
that did that so that must have done a
thing haha
wait no oh there we go now we're talking
so cool damn it I got the Coyotes stuck
in my grill oh god that's horrible well
then I'll just go this way sorry excuse
me pardon me good thing I didn't blow up
that that would have been too cool I'm
gonna win it even though I got coyote
running me the other way it's so cool
it's so cool this has been happy wheels
highlights thanks for watching if you
want to see more happy wheels right now
check the description or click the
annotation for the full happy wheels
playlist and if you want to see more
happy wheels in the future please click
the like button to let me know thanks
again everyone and as always I will see
you in the next video